The Joe Rogan Experience I heard
Benedict Donald like it was really like
another guy who was like Shane Roosevelt
I don't know if that's true I know what
happened with Benedict Arnold I just
know he is a traitor he rushed out of
West Point while George was there
Traders Hamilton they all chased out I'm
sure he I'm sure there's something there
but maybe his family that wrote that you
know it's like him and his wife
yeah he go to the
yeah he was a hero he was the captain of
Ford at West Point and uh yeah
slipped out he said that was the only
time they saw George Washington crying
whoa when yeah maybe it was because
he was with his wife yeah wouldn't she
was you got to get out of here baby
snuck out in the middle of the night
yeah like a [__] dude and then where
you go just straight to the Brits he
would there was ships out in the harbor
he just went out joined the British he
said here's how you take the fort or
whatever whoa he told him everything he
had to get in that's the way to get in
that's like everyone was his wife
British I'm not sure probably dirty
[__]
hot Russian broads come over here and
trick CIA guys trick our [__]
beautiful president Donald Trump
if you're a [__] guy in the
government you meet a hot Russian lady
like God damn it I'm [__] it's like
meeting a shark when you're in the ocean
right here
I just look good oh she's just a
ballerina nothing nothing weird about
this just plays violin yeah nothing
strange but he likes me and I'm
disgusting who's the politician that was
[__] the Chinese spy
[Music]
oh please don't tell me my wife found
out I was like no way worse worse she's
a Chinese spy and you opened up yeah
just thinking about being like Oh
suspected Chinese spy reportedly slept
with courted U.S officials to gain Intel
wow how many officials more than one
she's banging a bunch of guys so she's
really just a glorified prostitute
her name's Fang Fang no way there's
nothing funny her name is Fang oh it is
Fang Fang AKA Christina Fang entered the
U.S through California as a college
student in 2011 spent the next four
years wooing everyone from local
politicals to us Congressman The
Prostitute wow among the polls Fang got
close to was California Democrat Eric
swalwell and she once also once helped
raise funds for Tulsi gabbard uh oh she
was helpful on the way you think she's
[__] ever I don't think so she
probably was doing hopes
was like through it out there yeah
what's up
and someone being like dude your chick
he's like [__]
what a stupid [__] spy to just [__] a
mayor in Ohio we got a lot of
information out of this guy he's the
mayor of [__] Cleveland right
knows that the FBI is going to be in
town because of this now she's setting
back Morse code like the the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame is expanding awesome
but also Jake they're changing their
name to the Guardians the Cure is
winning but also she's a human being
yeah and even though she's working as a
spy maybe she just wanted to [__] the
mayor in a car human being she's Asian
unrelated you're saying yeah she was
like hey I'm trying a bigger thing but
this guy's cool yeah baby because she's
like it can't be all of her sex can't be
for Intel I don't know that's hot Intel
puss another U.S mayor described as
older and from obscure City in Midwest
called fang his girlfriend at a
conference in Washington DC in 2014. oh
damn bang bang sucking the mayor of
Suits mayor insisted the pair's
relationship was the real deal despite
their age differences oh she's [__]
old guys this doesn't work for me guys a
guy can't be a spy that [__] all the
she allegedly worked working at the
direction of Chinese ultrasound Ministry
of State security spy agency oxymoron
huh
interesting
God damn it who is she now in jail I
don't know where is she dude she got
traded for Brittany Greiner nah